vous avez fait des expériences sbt vous
avez fait des calculs en physique chimie
vous avez exploité votre travail en arts
plastiques
maintenant c'est à nous de reprendre le
blob après le travail des mains le
travail des mots au collège debussy de
saint germain en laye le blob inspire
les jeunes et les professeurs les élèves
dana jardin développent leur imaginaire
et leur capacité à s'exprimer dans la
tendance du moment en fait à considérer
que les élèves écrivent beaucoup mais
qu'on met un peu de côté la place de
l'oral ils sont très angoissés dès que
leur demande de passer et j'arrive à
voilà on va essayer de faire deux étapes
vous allez être capable de présenter un
projet de vous à les imaginer en groupe
et puis après on va passer à l'écrit
quatre heures d'enseignement par semaine
et des échanges personnels science
fiction horreur slam ou encore journal
intime ce travail met à profit toutes
les qualités qui nous intéressait dans
l'association c'est que on pouvait on
pouvait se projeter dans l'avenir et
imaginer et ça nous a aussi permis
d'arriver sur l'horreur un petit peu que
ça permet vraiment à tout le monde de
pouvoir s'exprimer dans ce qu'il est le
plus à l'aise donc moi ça va être pas le
dessin d'autre part la musique ça permet
vraiment à tout le monde de pouvoir
s'exprimer comme ils voudraient de pas
être mal à l'aise l'établissement saint
germanois continue son exploration
pluridisciplinaire dans le projet élèves
tombent loeb les élèves vont continuer à
travailler sur leur production jusqu'au
mois de mai le collège debussy tondre
allant la page de l'expérience autour
des blogs